Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
In meinem heutigen Video zeige ich euch,
wie ihr Hefe
vermehren könnt.
Eigentlich wollte ich dazu gar kein Video machen
und habe das einfach so jetzt nebenher gemacht.
Und dann sagt der Murat: "Was machst du denn da?"
Und dann habe ich gesagt:
"Ja, ich vermehre jetzt meine Hefe."
Denn momentan gibt es halt keine Hefe mehr,
keine frische Hefe zumindest.
Getrocknete Hefe gibt es natürlich immer im Backregal.
Ich habe auch immer Hefe eingefroren.
Aber so langsam werden die Vorräte knapp.
Und wenn ihr noch Hefewürfel zu Hause habt,
könnt ihr sie vermehren.
Und zwar machen wir das mithilfe eines Vorteiges.
Den Vorteig, den mache ich so auch gerne mal,
wenn ich einen Hefeteig zubereite.
Der bietet nämlich viele Vorteile.
Das nennt man auch indirekte Teigführung.
Also direkte Teigführung heißt einfach,
alle Zutaten für den Hefeteig in einen Topf geben,
verkneten und dann einen Hefeteig daraus zubereiten.
Funktioniert auch prima.
Aber, wenn ihr die indirekte Teigführung macht,
also mit Vorteig,
dann habt ihr die Vorteile,
dass ihr zum einen bessere Backeigenschaften habt,
eine bessere Krume habt
Das Gebäck bleibt länger frisch.
Es ist auch bekömmlicher.
Hat also wirklich viele, viele Vorteile.
Und ihr könnt eben weniger Hefe verwenden
und eben die Gehzeit geht dann auch um einiges schneller,
weil ihr dann eben schon einen Vorteig habt.
Und ihr könnt so eure Hefe einfach vermehren.
Also generell gilt bei Hefeteigen,
je mehr Hefe ihr benutzt, umso kürzer ist die Gehzeit,
und je weniger Hefe ihr benutzt,
umso länger müsst ihr warten.
Aber die längere Aufgehzeit bedeutet eben auch,
dass das Gebäck bekömmlicher wird,
es riecht weniger nach Hefe.
Aber die meisten nehmen einfach immer
einen Würfel Hefe pro 500 Gramm Mehl,
weil man dann eben nur
eine halbe Stunde bis Stunde den Teig aufgehen lässt.
Aber in allen Rezepten, die ich auch gemacht habe,
könnt ihr immer die Hefemenge reduzieren
oder eben auch erhöhen, wenn es schneller gehen soll.
Also ich nehme jetzt gleich einen halben Würfel Hefe
und daraus entsteht gleich wirklich viel Hefe!
Das könnt ihr wirklich supereinfach
zu Hause selber nachmachen.
Ihr nehmt dafür einfach 100 Milliliter lauwarmes Wasser,
einen halben Würfel Hefe,
15 Gramm Zucker
und 100 Gramm weißes Mehl.
Das heißt Mehl,
Weizenmehl, 405er, ein ganz helles Mehl.
Damit funktioniert es wirklich wunderbar.
Also hier habe ich das lauwarme Wasser.
Die Hefe kommt jetzt dazu.
Ich habe die jetzt aus dem Gefrierfach.
Aber ihr könnt auch ganz frische
aus dem Kühlregal nehmen.
Hefe nie zu lange aufheben,
weil dann einfach die Eigenschaften
wirklich verloren gehen.
Lieber dann gleich einfrieren.
Jetzt kommt da der Zucker dazu.
Dann das Mehl.
Das war es schon!
Die Arbeit ist jetzt erst mal getan.
Denn ihr lasst jetzt das Ganze abgedeckt
an einem warmen Ort.
Bei etwa 28°C wäre perfekt.
Aber ich habe ja jetzt hier auch warmes Wasser benutzt
und ich decke das Ganze jetzt ab.
Und es hat dann ungefähr auch schon die Temperatur.
Also abdecken und dann dauert das so etwa
je nach Temperatur 20 bis 30 Minuten.
Es kann schneller gehen, es kann länger dauern.
Aber das Volumen, das wird wirklich richtig groß!
Also das verdoppelt und verdreifacht,
vervierfacht sich sogar!
Ich mache gerade noch aus der übrigen Hälfte
der Hefe einfach noch mal die gleiche Menge.
Ihr müsst ein Gefäß nehmen, was groß genug ist,
weil es wirklich an Volumen zunimmt.
Und dann werde ich das Ganze gleich aufteilen.
Bei 28°C ist die Vermehrung der Hefe wirklich am besten.
Das ist die beste Temperatur dafür.
Und die Aufgehtemperatur für Hefeteige
liegt so etwa bei 34°C.
Da geht der Teig am besten auf.
Und ab 45°C sterben Hefekulturen.
Das heißt, im Backofen
stirbst sie dann eben ab beim Backen.
Und deswegen Hefeteig nie zu warm aufgehen lassen!
Also wirklich immer so bei 32°C, 34°C.
Das ist perfekt.
Nicht zu heiß.
Und jetzt warten wir mal ganz kurz,
bis das hier schön aufgeht.
Die Hefe ist echt krass gewachsen!
Also
ich habe das hier gerade eingefüllt
und kurz drei Minuten stehen lassen.
Und die ist schon wieder übergequollen.
Also ich fülle das hier jetzt einfach in Eiswürfelbehälter ein.
Immer so ungefähr 15 Gramm
pro Portion.
Ihr könnte es auch mit einem Spritzbeutel machen.
Das geht ein bisschen sauberer.
Habe ich vorhin auch schon gemacht.
Aber ich wollte euch einfach zeigen,
wie es auch hier mit einem Löffel geht.
Ihr könnt es auch hier ausgießen.
Aber dann...
Die Masse ist einfach so zäh.
Dann habt ihr vielleicht keine Kontrolle.
Jetzt fülle ich es hier ein
so bis kurz unter die Kante.
Und dann wird es sofort eingefroren.
Also ich muss jetzt auch hier nebendran
dieses Gefäß sofort einfrieren.
Ansonsten geht die Hefe jetzt gleich wieder auf.
Die wächst einfach
und lebt und atmet.
Ja. Und dann friere ich es ein,
kann es dann hier rausholen
und dann habe ich immer einen Hefewürfel.
Und ich probiere jetzt einfach ein paar Rezepte aus,
nehme euch mit in meinem Experiment
und dann habt ihr hoffentlich nach diesem Video
eine tolle Anleitung, wie ihr Hefe
selber machen könnt.
[Musik]
So.
Deckel drauf.
Schnell einfrieren!
Und hier jetzt einfach was Gefrorenes direkt oben drauflegen.
Dann wird es gleich fest.
Also hier ist jetzt unsere Hefe.
Und jetzt nur zeigen, wie Hefe selbst gemacht wird,
ist natürlich langweilig.
Ich probiere es gleich für euch aus.
Also hier bei der ersten Portion,
die habe ich ja sofort eingefroren,
hat es super geklappt.
Ihr seht auch einzelne schöne Hefewürfel.
Die zweite Portion ist ein bisschen eskaliert.
Da habe ich einfach zu lange gewartet.
Aber es macht nichts.
Ich drücke sie einfach auch gleich trotzdem raus.
Und jetzt mache ich mal einen süßen Hefeteig.
Den mache ich beim Nusszopf,
bei Buchteln, bei Hefegebäck.
Ist halt einfach so mein Standard-süßer-Hefeteig.
Und ich mache den normalerweise mit 500 Gramm Mehl.
Jetzt machen wir einen mit einem Kilo.
Und für 500 Gramm würde ich jetzt einen Würfel nehmen,
für ein Kilo nehme ich jetzt zwei.
Und das Ganze ist jetzt
ein bisschen anders als mit frischer Hefe.
Oder auch bei frischer Hefe ist es wirklich so
oder auch bei Trockenhefe,
je mehr Hefe ihr verwendet,
umso weniger Aufgehzeit braucht ihr.
Aber je weniger Hefe ihr benutzt,
umso bekömmlicher wird der Teig,
umso langsamer geht er natürlich auch auf,
aber er schmeckt dann halt auch feiner.
Das heißt, die Aufgehzeit
wird wahrscheinlich etwas länger sein.
So.
Eins.
Ist noch nicht ganz eingefroren,
aber das macht nichts.
Das kratze ich noch aus.
Perfekt!
Gleich wieder einfrieren.
Dann gebe ich da jetzt einfach ein bisschen Wasser dazu
zum Auflösen.
Sieht schon mal wunderbar aus.
Und jetzt kommt im Prinzip alles andere dazu.
Also Mehl.
Salz habe ich hier auch schon drin.
Eigelbe.
Und damit der Hefeteig extra saftig und schön wird,
nehme ich pro Kilo vier Eigelbe.
Also nicht zwei ganze Eier.
Dann etwas warme Milch.
Da behalte ich immer ein bisschen noch zurück.
Und dann Zucker.
Ich glaube, ich nehme heute weniger.
Ja.
Brauche ich jetzt nicht.
Ich weiß auch noch nicht,
was ich daraus zubereiten werde.
Wahrscheinlich einen Hefezopf
und vielleicht so kleine Teilchen
einfach zum Ausprobieren.
Und weiche Butter.
Perfekt.
Dann knete ich jetzt den Hefeteig
und lasse ihn dann an einem warmen Ort aufgehen
entweder in der Küchenmaschine
oder bei Gärstufe im Backofen.
Und gleich probiere ich noch einen herzhaften Teig,
also einen Pizzateig, aus
und sage euch, wie es geklappt hat.
Und ich bin richtig gespannt!
Also im Prinzip ist das Ganze ja jetzt, wie
einfach mit einem Vorteig zu arbeiten.
Ihr habt jetzt einen Vorteig hergestellt als Hefe
und,
ja, benutzt den jetzt weiter.
Hier ist auch schon mal Hefe...
Hefe sage ich schon.
...Hitze drauf.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Den Teig habe ich geknetet.
Und da ist echt wichtig,
Hefeteig immer lange kneten,
also etwa 10 Minuten.
Und der ist zwar schön weich,
aber er klebt eben nicht.
Also der hat eine richtig tolle Konsistenz.
Gut, ein bisschen klebrig ist er noch,
aber das ist gar nicht schlimm.
Ich habe ihn jetzt sogar 12 Minuten geknetet.
Ich will jetzt aber auch lieber, dass er weicher ist.
Jetzt fette ich hier meine Arbeitsfläche.
Also ganz normal wie immer.
Ich kann den Teig zu einer Kugel formen.
Und ich kann jetzt, wie gesagt,
auch gleich noch den herzhaften Teig ansetzen
für Pizza.
Da nehme ich jetzt aber nur
einen Würfel von der selbstgemachten Hefe.
Denn Pizzateig lasse ich oft
im Kühlschrank einfach aufgehen.
Oftmals auch bis zum nächsten Tag.
So wird er nämlich auch bekömmlicher.
Und vor allem kann man
sich das Pizzamachen gut vorbereiten.
Guck mal, wie gut der aussieht!
Zurück in die Schüssel.
Oh, bist du schön!
Etwas fetten, damit die Oberfläche nicht trocknet.
Und der kommt jetzt bei mir in den Dampfbackofen.
Denn das süße Hefegebäck
will ich jetzt gleich weiterverarbeiten.
Ja, Gärstufe.
[Musik]
So.
Also normalerweise braucht er
immer so 30 Minuten mit Dampf.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie lange er jetzt braucht.
Ich sage es euch auch gleich.
Aber ihr könnt ihn auch ganz einfach einpacken
und an einem warmen Ort schön aufgehen lassen,
bis er sich verdoppelt hat.
Also da geht man jetzt eher nicht auf die Zeit,
sondern eher auf das Volumen.
Wenn der Hefeteig sich verdoppelt hat,
dann ist er perfekt für die Weiterverarbeitung.
Bin gespannt.
So. Jetzt noch Pizzateig.
Da nehme ich jetzt nur einen Würfel.
Den lasse ich nämlich oft wirklich
einfach über Nacht aufgehen in unserem Kühlschrank.
Ich probiere es einfach.
Auf 900 Gramm Mehl.
Und da jetzt auch einfach wieder mit Wasser auflösen.
Ich hatte heute übrigens eben keine Lust auf eine Schürze.
Keine Schürze heute? Ei, ei, ei, Sally!
Und ich war so im
Chillmodus,
im Rezepteschreiben- und Vorbereitenmodus.
Deswegen.
[Musik]
Und hier einfach das Fett immer zum Schluss.
Also egal, ob Butter oder Öl,
immer nicht direkt auf die Hefe geben,
sondern wirklich erst zum Schluss zum Teig dazugeben.
[Musik]
Jetzt zeige ich euch mal beide Teige.
Und zwar habe ich den süßen Hefeteig
im Backofen bei Gärstufe aufgehen lassen
und dann einfach ohne.
So sieht der jetzt aus nach fünf Stunden,
also wirklich wunderschön.
Und
er riecht einfach total lecker
und angenehm und gar nicht nach Hefe.
Also echt super!
Das ist der Pizzateig aus dem Kühlschrank.
Der ging jetzt wirklich kaum auf.
Aber im Kühlschrank geht Hefe eben auch langsamer auf.
Deswegen stellt man ihn ja auch in den Kühlschrank.
Den lasse ich jetzt einfach
über Nacht im Kühlschrank stehen.
Ich probiere es einfach aus.
Und den will ich jetzt heute Abend
eigentlich auch nicht mehr weiterverarbeiten.
Daher würde ich den jetzt entweder in den Kühlschrank stellen
oder in die Garage.
Was sagst du?
Ich glaube, Kühlschrank, weil die Garage...
Ich glaube, heute Nacht gibt es sogar noch mal Frost.
Also stelle ich jetzt einfach beides in den Kühlschrank,
benutze es morgen früh
und dann sehen wir einfach gleich, wie es schmeckt
und wie die Verwendung ist.
Aber der Teig sieht echt bombastisch aus!
Beides jetzt abdecken
und eine Nacht ruhen lassen.
Aber, wie gesagt, den könnte man
jetzt auch direkt weiterverwenden.
Man sieht es ganz gut.
Der ging richtig schön auf,
ist schön locker.
Ich will ihn gar nicht anfassen,
weil er so
so perfekt aussieht,
so richtig schön.
Guck mal. Tack.
Toll!
Es hat alles super geklappt!
Guckt mal, mein Hefeteig.
Der war jetzt über Nacht im Kühlschrank.
Jetzt habe ich ihn aber schon
vor zwei Stunden etwa aus dem Kühlschrank raus,
damit er einfach wieder schön warm wird
zur Weiterverarbeitung.
Aber wie gesagt, hätte ich den gestern schon
weiterverarbeiten können.
Der Vorteil ist,
ich rieche dran und er reicht einfach nicht hefig.
Normalerweise ist es ja wirklich so,
wenn man Hefeteig zu lange stehen lässt, säuert er.
Dieser gar nicht.
Das ist jetzt...
Gut, der ist jetzt ein bisschen nass geworden
durch den Kühlschrank.
Dieser ist jetzt der süße Hefeteig.
Und denn drittel ich jetzt und mache zum einen
kleine Hefeschnecken mit Nougat.
Dann mache ich noch so kleine Häschen und Nestchen.
Ja.
Und so was wie Watruschki.
Guckt mal.
So ein schöner Teig!
Der riecht toll,
sieht super aus,
die Teigkonsistenz ist perfekt!
Also es hat echt super geklappt!
So. Einmal dritteln.
Ach, ist das schön!
So. Jetzt machen wir die Hefeschnecken mit Nougat.
Ich kann hier schon mal mein Blech nehmen.
Butter ist drin.
Das schmelze ich jetzt hier einfach bei niedriger Stufe.
Perfekt!
Dann nehme ich noch Nougat hier rein.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach Classic Nougat
von Viba, unser Lieblingsnougat.
Hier hatte ich sogar noch ein bisschen.
Das kann ich jetzt auch schmelzen.
[Musik]
Ich forme jetzt einfach so kleine, dünne, lange Stränge.
Und die lasse ich kurz liegen.
So entspannt sich der Teig.
Und dann
legt ihr die zwei Stränge übereinander
und verzwirbelt sie zweimal.
Unten schön ein Loch lassen.
Die zwei Stränge sind jetzt hier oben die Hasenohren.
Und da unten in die Öffnung
kommt dann noch das kleine Schwänzchen rein.
[Musik]
Dann gibt es jetzt hier noch geflochtene Kränze.
Also einfach drei Stränge nehmen
und wie bei den Haaren
oder wie bei Freundschaftsbändchen
einfach von außen in die Mitte
von rechts nach links einmal flechten.
[Musik]
Dann kurz entspannen lassen
und hier auf dem Blech zu einem Kranz legen.
Und hier einfach auch die Enden miteinander verknüpfen.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt lauter 60-Gramm-Bällchen.
Also so circa 60 Gramm.
Das werden gleich die Watruschki.
Da gibt es auch ein Rezept schon auf dem Kanal.
Perfekt eingefettet!
Perfekt geschmolzen!
Hier habe ich jetzt den restlichen Teig noch ausgerollt.
Ta-ta-ta-taa!
Da kommt jetzt Nougat rein.
Oh, da freuen sich jetzt alle drauf!
Ich habe es noch nicht gesagt, dass ich
Nougatschnecken mache.
Ich hatte Nougatbuchteln mal gemacht.
Da sind sie schon alle ausgeflippt.
Jetzt machen wir Nougatschnecken!
Ganz geschmolzen habe ich es jetzt nicht.
Ah, nee! Das ist der Crisp da drinnen.
Stimmt! Der eine Nougat war mit Crisp.
O Gott!
Oh, ich glaube, ich mache gleich noch mehr Crisp rein.
Ich mache Haselnüsse!
Haselnussstücke!
Aylin, was sagst du dazu?
Perfekt!
Geröstete Haselnüsse.
O Gott, ich kriege gerade so Hunger!
Ta-ta-ta-taa!
Und hier.
Nusskrokant.
Lecker!
Ist sogar schon geröstet.
Das riecht man direkt.
Was aus so einem Experiment alles entsteht, nicht?
So einfach mal kurz drei verschiedene Desserts.
Dann noch Pizza.
Oh, Stromboli können wir auch machen
wie im Buch.
Und ich bin echt glücklich mit der Hefe!
Denn
man hat einfach mehr Verarbeitungszeit.
Die Hefe wird einfach dann nicht schlecht,
der Hefeteig.
Jetzt schön aufrollen.
Perfekt kann man sie jetzt machen,
wenn man die Rolle dann noch einfriert.
Dann hat man wirklich so
eine perfekte, schöne Schnecke.
Und ich glaube, wir frieren sie ein.
Ich will, dass die Schnecke perfekt wird.
Also wickel ich das jetzt hier so rein,
richtig schön fest.
Und dann kommt es in den Gefrierschrank.
Und sobald die Rolle so ein bisschen angefroren ist,
kann ich sie
ohne Silikonmatte natürlich
schön in Scheiben schneiden,
hier reinsetzen
und dann habe ich schöne Nougatschnecken.
Oh, das ist jetzt wie so eine...
Ach ja, jetzt können wir wirklich unser Workout machen.
Hier, so.
Zack, zack, zack, zack.
Hi, Schatz!
Ich habe das Hefeexperiment gemacht und das ist
so gut geworden!
Ich bin so glücklich gerade!
Ich gehe gerade voll auf!
Ja.
Ich habe hier Nougatschnecken.
Ich habe auch ein Hefeexperiment gemacht.
Und das Ding ist explodiert!
Ja.
Nougatschnecken.
Dann mache ich noch so Watruschki
mit Aprikosen.
Und dann habe ich noch so kleine süße Osterhäschen
und Hefekranz.
Und gleich mache ich noch Pizza.
Okay.
Und Stromboli.
Frohe Ostern wünsche ich euch.
Ich wollte nur meine Hefe vermehren
und jetzt bin ich so
explodiert.
Ich habe es ja auch vermehrt
und ich bin auch explodiert.
Habe ich auch gemacht.
Machst du mir kurz das Gefrierfach auf?
Ja.
Welches von den zehn?
Jetzt geht es weiter mit den Watruschki.
Ich mache es jetzt doch nicht so watruschkimäßig,
sondern eher eiförmig.
Wir haben ja jetzt Frühjahr und bald Ostern.
Also rolle ich die jetzt hier oval aus.
Ich glaube, das Hefevideo wird länger, als ich dachte.
Ich dachte, es wird so 10 Minuten kurz.
Okay.
Aber ich dachte mir: Komm.
Das zeige ich euch jetzt auch alles noch, die Ideen.
Und dann einfach
einen großen Eisportionierer voll von der Füllung.
Die schreibe ich euch auch in die App.
Das ist einfach die Watruschki-Füllung.
[Musik]
Hier jetzt noch eine Aprikose drauf.
Und fertig.
Die können schon gebacken werden.
[Musik]
Jetzt gibt es noch Pizza.
Guckt mal hier, der Hefeteig!
Ich habe jetzt hier nur doch noch mal
einen Würfel selbstgemachter Hefe dazugegeben.
Einfach, dass er eben doch ein bisschen mehr aufgeht.
Also bei der selbstgemachten
doch nicht zu sehr sparen
und wirklich pro 500 Gramm einen Würfel.
Das passt perfekt.
Und den habe ich jetzt hier auch
noch mal bei Zimmertemperatur gehabt,
vorhin auch noch mal in der Gärstufe.
Also,
wenn der auch Wärme kriegt, ist der auch wirklich super.
Ich denke, so mit zwei Würfeln
wäre er jetzt auch schön im Kühlschrank aufgegangen.
Jetzt mache ich die Pizzasoße.
Das mache ich meistens einfach hier.
Das heißt Tomaten aus der Dose,
etwas Tomatenmark,
Zwiebel und Knoblauch.
Da gibt es aber auch schon Rezepte auf meinem Blog.
Und was macht die Frau vom schwäbischen Mann immer?
Ausspülen?
Ausspülen.
Ja, die gute Tomate.
Oh, es ist ja schon was fertig.
Die Riesenzwiebel, die halbiere ich mal.
Ich viertel sie.
Tomatenmark.
Knoblauch und
Gewürze mache ich zum Schluss.
So habe ich immer den Vorteil,
dass die Kinder die Zwiebeln nicht sehen
und die Knoblauchzehen.
Weil die denken immer bei selbstgemachter Pizza,
wenn ich Zwiebeln dann reinmache,
dass andere Italiener das nie machen,
weil sie sehen halt die Zwiebel dann nie.
Und hier sagen sie immer:
"Mama, ohne Zwiebel!"
Und so schmecken sie es und sehen es nicht raus.
[Musik]
Ach, guckt euch den schönen Pizzateig mal an!
Der sieht doch einfach perfekt aus!
Ich habe jetzt gedacht,
weil jetzt alle aus dem Team wieder mitesssen,
machen wir doch kein Stromboli.
Wir machen wirklich nur
Pizza.
Da freuen sich jetzt alle drauf.
Ich mache jetzt sechs kleinere,
also so sechs mittelgroße.
Der Teig ist auch viel, viel
elastischer
und so.
Also man merkt das eigentlich so.
Durch den Vorteig, durch die lange
Gehzeit
einfach besser zum Handhaben.
Ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen Grieß.
[Musik]
So gibt es einen leckeren knusprigen Boden.
Ganz kurz entspannen.
Dann geht es gleich weiter.
Guckt mal.
Wenn der Teig so kurz liegen geblieben ist,
dann geht das Öffnen wirklich supereinfach.
Lalala Lalalaa Lalalala Lalalaa.
Ho-la-re-di-hi!
Ich fühle mich echt wie die Mutter von
Frederico,
wie die immer so Essen für alle macht.
Aylin, sag bloß. Du kennst die Werbung nicht?
Von Miracoli.
Oje, oje.
[Musik]
Und jetzt gibt es hier die Nougatschnecken.
Ich denke,
ich mache das jetzt so.
Guckt mal, wie perfekt der Anschnitt dann ist!
Mega, oder?
[Musik]
Das war mein Hefevideo!
Also ihr habt gesehen, hat alles super geklappt,
herzhaft und auch süß.
Die Hefe ist bei mir eingefroren.
Entweder lasst ihr sie in Eiswürfelbehältern
mit Deckel natürlich
oder ihr nehmt sie jetzt raus
und füllt sie in ein Mepal-Gefäß
oder in ein anderes verschlossenes Gefäß.
Und ja, die Pizza haben wir jetzt schon gegessen.
Die war echt superlecker!
Da schmeckt nichts hefig.
Es klappt alles wunderbar.
Also probiert es gerne aus.
Schreibt mir euer Feedback.
Und ich freue mich wirklich auf eure Rückmeldung.
Und wenn ihr noch Wünsche habt, Ideen oder Anregungen,
schreibt sie mir gerne.
Ihr seht, wir setzen sie dann superschnell um
für euch.
Und ja,
ich wünsche euch noch eine richtig schöne Zeit.
Und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüssi!
Und alle Rezepte, die ich hier gemacht habe,
schreibe ich euch natürlich in die App.